>> For every element in Y, if there exists an element that
is after it, then that element must be greater than or
equal to the current element we're looking at. Almost there, okay.
you, what, Jarrod did is he broke the specification into two parts.
One part is all the elements except the last one. And he, he stated exactly what
the post-conditions is for that. But he didn't say anything about the last one.
Okay, so if we wanted to have a precise specification, we'd have to deal with,
with that one as well. Okay? Now, it turn out in this particular case that we
can do a little proof in our head. To say that if the post condition that
he specified for all the other element is true, that implies that the last one
must be the greatest one. So, we could get we could get away with that, and
in fact that's a pretty nice, clean way of expressing it. Notice,
also, that Jared used the word" for each," and when you hear that phrase,
it's suggestive of, in our first-order logic,
of one of those quantifiers that I mentioned, the universal quantifier, for
each or for all. And so we're going to, we're going to see when we specify
this in first order logic that that, that quantifier is going to be there.
First order logic when we introduce a quantifier at the same time that,
or, when we use the quantifier at the same time we introduce a variable which is
going to stand for the typical element of the vector. Okay, so
for each i where i is going to be an index position into y,
then we can say something about the value that's held in position i and
the position i plus one Okay? So, the quantifier for each has a variable
that comes with it we can call it i or j or whatever you would like.